- I love sharing cultures.
You know, one way obviously
to get to know different cultures is food.
So I wanna know what's a food
that you love that you think
that everyone should try?
Maybe like a dessert.
- Oh, you're talking about pandan cake?
- Yeah.
- I mean, so pandan cake is,
how would you describe it?
It's a plant.
- I want you to describe
it. It's your interview.
- It's a very,
(audience laughs)
I could turn the tables again.
(host and audience laughs)
It's a plant.
It's a very specific green color,
they make like cakes and stuff out of it.
And it sort of tastes like
it's a little bit bitter,
but it's a little bit vanilla tasting too.
It's a very specific taste.
And a lot of like far East Asian countries
have a dessert made from it.
And it was my favorite
dessert flavor growing up.
And it's very hard to find here, did you-
- Are you on dessert right now?
If I materialized one
right in front of you,
hypothetically, would
you, you would eat some?
- Don't say stuff you can't-
- [Host] Justin, let's just bring it out
and let's just see.
(audience applauds)
- Oh my God.
- Thank you so much,
Justin. That's wonderful.
Here you go.
- That is amazing.
You got pandan cake. Oh my God.
- This is from one of your
favorite bakeries, I believe,
Mina, right?
- Oh, really?
- [Host] minahrocks.la?
- Yeah, she made it, that's amazing
- [Host] Let's try it right now.
- Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
- I love watching you eat carbs.
- [Guest] It's so good.
- You know, it just makes me happy.
- Oh my God.
- And it makes me feel a
little bit better about myself.
- So there's, there's gotta
be, this is only two slices.
(audience laughs)
There's gotta be rest of the
cake here somewhere, right?
I'm not joking.
- I think we can arrange that.
- Wait, why are you putting it down?
- Well, 'cause it's a little
dry without some liquid
and it was a perfect segue to my thing.
- Yes.
- [Host] 'Cause you know
what I like is boba.
- Yes, you love boba.
- And I think we have some of that too
(audience applauds)
out there, Justin could you?
Perfect.
- Thank you.
- Very welcome.
- Thank you so much.
Some boba from Boba Guys.
- So now we're having some
pandan cake with some boba.
- Oh my God, I'm so happy right now.
(audience laughs)
This is great.
Oh, I did not think this was gonna happen.
- I was afraid that you were gonna tell me
that you couldn't eat any of it.
- No, I can do whatever I want.
Movies out. I don't give a-
- [Host] Yeah, wow.
(audience laughs and applauds)